[Music]
CBS is unveiling its new 2017 primetime
lineup thank you very much the network
will introduce six new series for the
fall along with twenty-three returning
shows the critically acclaimed comedy
mom is coming back yay it stars
emmy-winning actress Allison Janney and
Anna Faris powerhouse producer that
would be you Chuck Lorre is a show's
co-creator Lorie is a creative force
behind a number of hits including TV's
number one comedy with more than 18
million viewers the Big Bang Theory this
fall Laurie's bringing us a new comedy
called young Sheldon it's hilarious a
Big Bang Theory spin-off is about genius
Sheldon Cooper think of this growing up
in East Texas and going to high school
at nine years old
yes Sheldon per the student dress and
grooming code this boy's hair is too
long this boy's wearing sports attire
outside of a designated area and this
girl's blouses diaphanous which means I
can see her brassiere thank you I will
take that into account we have a few
minutes before first period I need y'all
to fill out these forms but also in
violation of the grooming code on page
48 article 5 subsection B you have a bit
of a mustache
glory and Allison Janney are here they
join us at the table I watched it last
night it's hilarious there's there's a
funny line that I know Charlie Rose you
have never said are you Chuck Lorre to
his mother he says is when should I be
expecting my testicles to drop that's it
no that's all he said when should I be
expecting my team it had been proceeding
at a conversation this is testicles
dropping yeah I just where does this
thank you yell King that's what we're
going to talk about should I be
expecting my test seemed like the
appropriate conversation to have in
church but this is this is what's so
great about it because he really does
channel Jim Parsons his election sound
like them his thinking sounds like them
him I know that's all very deliberate
where did this come where it go we've
been talking about we've been talking
about Sheldon's backstory on BIGBANG for
10 years
you know and his very religious mother
and and the football environment that he
grew up in and and actually was Jim
Parsons who contacted me and said let's
do that let's make that a show and I
went yeah yes you know we've been
talking about it for a decade let's do
it and where did you find a an Armitage
Ian sent us a tape of an audition tape
from Maryland I believe and it was
astonishing it was like oh good lord
could we possibly be this lucky it last
night I was working the room yeah it
really was
he's a remarkable little boy we just got
hit by lightning remember he was
standing there because he like likes
Broadway and all the sudden he says you
know I know the lead song from Sunset
Boulevard would you like me to sing it
and go and he was like oh I mean he
wouldn't do a whole big thing just there
on the spot
so did you what do Jim work with him to
get the inflections Jim Jim was
essentially an acting coach as well as
an executive producer on this pilot and
will continue to do so I mean who better
to teach him how to play this part than
Jim Parsons we're very lucky to have
that work out you've got another show on
CBS of course mom and house and you're
coming back fifth fifth season the
season yeah I'm very excited that we get
another another season to tell these
stories can you give us a tiny preview
without revealing the whole plot line
for this season no Alison you're doing
what that's what I think it's so amazing
yes you're doing Broadway 60 weeks and
doing is do currently and that's running
through July 16th and issues Dana it's
outstanding
it's a great play I think it is
startling he came to be really funny
that I didn't know he was in the
audience I would oh no I don't want to
make you nervous no no I didn't feel
but but yeah I'm excited it's been you
know I thought it would be a relaxing
hiatus for me going back to the Broadway
but it's in sixth the Broadway is a is a
is a tough but you knew what you were
getting into yeah I did it's been a
while but it's it's a lot of fun it's a
lot of work eight shows a week and and
but I look forward to coming coming back
to my my mom home it's Emmys are coming
out Emmy nominations rather coming out
in July and word is that you will be
nominated the show will be nominated and
normally shows embark on a big Emmy
campaign yes and you guys have decided
you know you're not doing that this year
how come when we discussed with water
brothers the production company behind
mom uh what our Emmy campaign might be
and we spent on Emmy campaign yes a lot
of money and I just blurted out let's
give the money to Planned Parenthood and
they took me seriously and which is
great because our show is all about
women and we are don't shy away from
dealing with all issues that affect
women and families and Planned
Parenthood is such an important
organization that that helps to give
health services to millions of women and
families and it's in danger of the House
of Representatives order to defund it
and it's such a critical time it made
sense that we stand up now and and and
say something encourage other people to
to donate to Planned Parenthood and help
this organization even a t-shirt yes I I
definitely wanted to let everyone know
why not everybody will be happy about
that but you all decided that's what you
want to do yeah all right we don't shy
away from controversy not on this show
no and you don't know and it's important
to say you know it's not a it's not a
statement about the Emmys we'd love love
to be included but it just seemed like
such a better way to put that money to
work thank you guys are being here
continued successes are great thank you